ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sendung
heute geht es um das Thema
Ideologien politische Ideologien genau
genommen dieses Thema hängt ganz eng mit
einem anderen Thema zusammen nämlich mit
dem Thema Macht und Herrschaft mach oben
rechts ein Link zu dieser Sendung hinein
wir werden heute genau untersuchen wie
Ideologien in politischen Kontexten
macht
legitimieren und auch zu Gewalt Exzessen
führen können deswegen muss in jeder
politischen Theorie immer auch der
Begriff der Ideologie das Phänomen der
Ideologie Beachtung finden der Begriff
der Ideologie ist mit anderen Worten ein
politischer Grundbegriff der nicht
irgendwie was äußerliches bezeichnet
sondern der eine Grundproblematik eine
Grundtendenz alles politischen
bezeichnet ganz allgemein kann man sagen
dass das
politische immer im Zusammenhang steht
von Individuen die in einem Verhältnis
zu anderen Individuen stehen und die
versuchen durch Organisation dieses
Zusammenlebens stabile Systeme zu
erlangen dabei muss allerdings auch
betont werden dass immer auch in solchen
Zusammenkünften den politischen dem
Zusammenkommen von Individuen die Frage
nach der Macht und Herrschaft eine große
Rolle spielen denn wenn Individuen sich
zusammenfinden sind sie keine bloßen
Aggregate keine bloßen
zusammelwürfelten Mengen sondern sie
sind organisiert das politische ist
nicht nur eine Menge von Menschen
sondern eine
Organisation wie genau diese
Organisation zu verstehen ist das ist
natürlich immer die Frage entscheidend
für die Art und Weise der Organisation
ob es jetzt diese Form wird oder diese
ist der Machtanspruch das das heißt
Organisationsformen sind immer auf
machtinessen bezogen
idealerweise wird die Machtfrage im
politischen so gelöst dass alle zur
gleichen Teilen partizipieren das ist
der Gedanke der Demokratie doch ist ja
leider nicht so leicht zu realisieren
und auch hinsichtlich dieser Frage
gibt's ganz verschiedene Auffassung wie
das Verhältnis von Individum und
kollektiv im Falle einer Demokratie noch
zu sehen ist soll es eine Parlament AR
ische Demokratie sein soll es eine
repräsentative oder eine direkte
Demokratie sein hier sieht man schon
hier stellt sich wieder die
Machtfrage selbst dem ganz rudimentären
Fall in diesem
protopolitischen Fall dass nur das Recht
des Stärkeren die Organisationsform
vorgibt das also wenige im Sinne einer
Tyrannis oder eines Tyrannen
ähm eine Oligarchie ähm die politische
Ordnung bestimmen selbst dann bedarf es
einer
Legitimation der Herrschaft und die kann
allein auch schon darin bestehen dass
man nur die Gewalt
androh gewaltantrohen ist auch eine Form
von Gewalt oder
machtlegitimierung das kann darin
bestehen dass man den anderen Angst
macht dass man einfach Macht
demonstriert Machtdemonstration ist
nicht im strengen Sinne macht
Ausübung sondern eine machtankündigung
die ein Herrschaftsanspruch artikuliert
als eine Aussage die bestimmt wie
Herrschaftsformen
Herrschaftsverhältnisse zu regeln sind
eine ganz große Rolle eine ganz wichtige
Bedeutung spielen bei solchen Fragen
nach
herrschaftslegitimation die Ideologien
Ideologie ist also sehr sehr zentral und
darauf wollen wir uns jetzt heute
konzentrieren woher kommt überhaupt das
Wort Ideologie ganz einfach es kommt vom
griechischen Wort idea das ist die Idee
und lookos das ist lehere Wissenschaft
Logik mir gefällt jetzt hier das Wort
die Übersetzung Logik am besten warum
werde ich genau noch zeigen nach meiner
Übersetzung wäre es jetzt die Logik der
Idee die Logik der Idee die das
Zusammenleben betrifft natürlich es ist
eine Logik die eine bestimmte Idee
beinhaltet eine ideenlogik und die
ideenlogik betrifft die Frage nach des
dem Zusammenleben von Individuen nach
der Herrschaftsform
m man kann natürlich sagen Ideologien
sind jede Form von Weltanschauung auch
Religionen ich halte das aber für
problematisch weil Ideologien viel viel
spezifischer sind und eine ganz eigene
Logik haben was Religionen und andere
Weltanschauung so nicht haben ich bin
auch der Meinung Liberalismus oder
Sozialismus oder andere Formen der
politischen Einstellung die wir im
Spektrum der demokratischen Parteien
finden sind keine Ideologien warum nicht
werde ich noch zeigen der Grund besteht
ganz allgemein darin dass sie nicht zu
exklusiv sind so sind sind integrativ
z.B kann man sozialliberal sein also man
kann sozialistisch sein aber auch etwas
liberal das ist alles möglich man kann
auch konservativ und liberal sein man
kann auch konservativ und sozialistisch
orientiert sein soziale Marktwirtschaft
das schließt sich nicht aus Ideologien
hingegen tendieren dazu exklusiv zu sein
oder auch anders gesagt exklusivistisch
Sie haben die Tendenz auszuschließen und
nicht sich mit anderen Weltanschauung zu
verbinden und das macht sie eben gerade
auch sehr problematisch
Ideologien beschreiben jetzt das
Zusammenleben nicht nur sondern bewerten
es auch sie sagen welche Form des
politischen Zusammenlebens die Beste ist
und oft gibt's nur eine das ist die
einzig wahre Form des Zusammenlebens die
einzig wahre Form der
Herrschaftsausübung das heißt Ideologien
sind
[Musik]
normativ sie können stärker oder
schwächer normativ sein je nachdem wie
große Anspruch ist betrifft die
Ideologie nur eine regionale Form des
Zusammenlebens oder eine globale in der
Regel tendieren aber Ideologien zum
globalistischen denken genauer gesagt
zum universalen Anspruch
äh und sie verstehen sich auch als
exklusiv das heißt sie tolerieren keine
konkurrierenden Ideologien neben sich es
ist also eigentlich ein Kampf der
politischen Ideen der
letztgültigen politischen Ideen deswegen
besitzen Ideologien häufig auch
totalitären Anspruch sie wollen alles
bestimmen alles erklären alles regeln
was die Macht anbelangt und da kommt
wieder der Begriff der Logik ins Spiel
sie sind in sich schlüssig sie sind
kohärent weil sie so sehr auf Ideen auf
ideale Zustände häufig auch ein Ziel
vorgeben wohin sich das politisch
entwickeln sollte das ist ja auch das
normative also ist ein noch zu
erfüllender noch zu realisierender
Zustand des politischen dadurch können
sie häufig auch nicht durch empirische
Erfahrungen widerlegt werden sie
immunisieren sich also gegen Kritik von
außen äh und sie sind erhaben gegenüber
konkreten politischen Zuständen das kann
man eine Form von Blasenbildung nennen
wir kennen solche Form auch im digitalen
und es führt zu einer
Radikalisierung häufig sind Ideologien
sehr einleuchten weil sie auf scheinbar
oder auch wirklich intuitiven
Grundannahmen basieren diese
Intuitivität von Ideologien verdankt
sich einer Simplifizierung der Welt also
Ideologien sind gerade dann sehr aktiv
wenn die Welt unübersichtlich zu werden
trot wie zu Beginn des 20 Jahrhunderts
und auch noch Mitte des 20 Jahrhunderts
keine Zeit ist davor gefeit der Moderne
für politische Ideologien anfällig zu
werden weil die politischen Verhältnisse
immer weiter komplizierter werden auch
vermittelt durch die Medien häufig wird
dann als Ursache für die Probleme eine
Bevölkerungsgruppe herausgegriffen die
die alleinige Schuld trägt das ist
natürlich ein großes Problem weil es
hier dann auch schnell Richtung
Diskriminierung geht Ideologien neigen
auch zu Verschwörungstheorien also
verborgene Mächte hinter komplexen
politischen Erscheinungen zu vermuten
die die einzige Ursache sind auch hier
wieder Tendenz der Simplifizierung im
Nationalsozialismus od auch im
Kommunismus hat man das gesehen dadurch
aber weil dieses Bild diese Idee so
simplifizierend und so intuitiv ist
erlaubt sie eben auch eine besonders
radikale Form von
machtlegitimation sie braucht sich nicht
mehr kritischen einwenden zu stellen
sondern ist sich ihrer ganz gewiss und
das führt eben dann in der Regel auch zu
großer Gewalt die nicht mehr sich selbst
kritisch reflektieren muss ja sie
besitzen eine transempirische Struktur
das habe ich schon gesagt sie sind Ideen
die ein Istzustand ähm nicht bezeichnen
s ein sollenszustand wie die Welt
politisch sein soll also ein Ideal ist
dahinter ist also nicht nur eine
Ideologie sondern eine ideallogik die
dahinter steht und die führt natürlich
auch zu einer verzerrten Sicht einer
selektiven Sicht auf die Wirklichkeit
aus dieser Perspektive der
Geschlossenheit des ideologischen
Systems muss jede andere kritische
Perspektive als eine Gefahr und
Bedrohung diese Idee interpretiert
werden was natürlich wieder zu
Gewalteskalation führen kann ja das war
in aller Kürze eine Darstellung und
Problematisierung der Ethologie ich
bedanke mich vielmals für die
Aufmerksamkeit bis zu einer nächsten
Sitzung